Joe Rogan was just talking to the Rock
these guys are probably pretty decent
reflections of the American populace at
large here's their conversation about
the sitting president of the United
States when I was a
kid you could have a republican friend
like it was no big deal yes it's no big
deal like oh Bobby likes George Bush who
cares who gives a you know you were a
supporter of Bill Clinton he liked
George Bush nobody cared nobody like you
you know it wasn't like you're a Nazi
like I'm what I mean I'm a Nazi I just
want
taxes what the are you talking about how
did I become a Nazi dude it's it's the
craziest thing I have friends who
support Trump I have friends who support
Biden I have friends do you really have
friends who support Biden come on well
no no no no no here's here's what I do I
have I have friends thank you that's a
good check cuz that's important this is
important context they support the
Democratic party I have friends who are
loyal to the party
yes no devastating and really great
catch by Joe